I'm Marlene said in Doha here top
stories on Al Jazeera we start with some
breaking news at least one Palestinian
has been killed and 22 others injured
during an Israeli raid on Janine refugee
camp in the occupied West Bank this
morning four people are in critical
condition and they are reports that two
Palestinians were detained including
Hamas activists Israel has stepped up
its raids in the occupied West Bank in
the past few years to crack down of
Palestinian resistance to its occupation
mostly in the cities of Janine and
Nablus let's speak to our correspondent
Anita Ibrahim who joins us on the line
from the occupied West Bank Nina what
more can you tell us about what's
happened this morning
well according to the Palestinian Health
Ministry at least one Palestinian has
been killed by Israeli forces fire in
Janine after Israeli causes raided the
camp now these raids are becoming some
sort of a usual occurrence Israelis want
to Target the armed groups of
Palestinians working together fighting
against Israeli forces but this morning
the difference was that there was an
attack by Palestinian Fighters against
Israeli soldiers leading to the injury
of at least five Israeli soldiers this
is why we're seeing an escalation we're
seeing uh Israeli military planes on top
of genuine uh shooting towards
Palestinians that are of course on the
ground forces as well and Palestinians
are saying that the Israeli forces are
shooting
indiscriminately like targeting
Palestinians and their homes and we've
heard from Israeli military sources that
they are sending planes to try and
Evacuate the soldiers it's a tense
situation engineering and it is expected
to continue so because it's kind of very
rare for us to see it's really a plane
shooting and and sending barrages uh
from the military planes on top of
people living in the Janine area okay
thank you for that Anita Ibrahim there
for us in the occupied West Bank